Der Besitzer dieser Bierflasche
auf Rädern ist ein lebenslustiger Mensch,
aber auf den Tod hat er sich
vorbereitet wie kaum ein anderer.
Denn in diesem Gefährt
wird Martin Brunnschweiler
eines Tages seine letzte Reise antreten.
Es ist seltsam? Nein, es ist sehr bequem!
Ich weiß, wahrscheinlich sieht es für einige
Leute gruselig aus. Aber das stört mich nicht.
Am Ende wird der Tod
jeden ereilen. Das ist eben die Realität.
Man sollte es einfach etwas leichter nehmen.
Der 47-jährige Brite hat sein Leben dem Bier
gewidmet. Er braut Bier auf der „Isle of Man“.
Vor 30 Jahren hat ihm sein Bruder
das passende Gefährt dazu gebastelt.
Aus einem alten Citroën wurde die fahrende
Bierflasche, die hier auf der Insel jeder kennt.
Dann hörte er von einer Firma,
die Särge auf Wunsch baut.
Es ist ein Kunstwerk, und ich bin stolz, dieses
Fahrzeug für meine letzte Reise zu haben.
Ich mag dieses Innenfutter.
Es ist sehr luxuriös.
Anfertigen ließ er sich seine
kuriose Kiste bereits vor sechs Jahren.
Man kann sehen, dass es alles handgemacht
ist: alle diese kleinen Details aus Holz,
wirklich alles, diese kleinen Scheibenwischer,
die Spiegel.
Ich liebe die Malereien. Es ist alles
von Hand gemalt. Ich liebe das Ganze.
Gebaut wurde der außergewöhnliche
Sarg im englischen Nottingham.
In der Sargmanufaktur „Vic Fearn“ unter der
Marke „Crazy Coffins“
sind in den letzten Jahren mehrere einhundert
verrückte Särge entstanden.
Gemeinsam mit seinen Kollegen entwirft und
baut John Voce die Friedhofs-Hingucker.
Dies wird ein Flugzeug. Zwischen 1.000 und
3.500 Euro
kostet so ein handgemachtes Unikat.
Ich denke, das technisch Herausforderndste
war der Rolls Royce,
weil wir für alles eigene Formen machen
mussten, sogar für die Schutzbleche.
Wir mussten sie biegen, ausprobieren, was
klappt, und dann kleben.
Also, da steckt wirklich viel Arbeit drin.
Im Lagerraum der Sargmanufaktur
stehen neben Kopien auch Originale,
die auf ihren Einsatz warten.
Oft können die
Trauergäste später leicht erraten,
was der Verstorbene im
Leben besonders schätzte
oder was sein größter unerfüllter Traum war.
Der Mann, der das hier bestellt hat,
ist ein großer Blackpool Fan.
Das ist sein Fußballklub-Logo.
Er ist noch quicklebendig und er war
hiermit schon auf einigen Ausstellungen.
Doch nicht alles ist amüsant.
Manchmal müssen die Sargmacher
auch mit ihren Gefühlen kämpfen
– vor allem, wenn es um Kinder geht.
Das war das Musikinstrument eines Kindes.
Und dann erfährt man,
dass es plötzlich gestorben ist,
und wir hatten nicht viel Zeit es herzustellen.
Das ist dann ziemlich traurig.
Für sich selbst hat
John Voce noch keinen Sarg gemacht,
auch wenn er schon klare Vorstellungen hat.
Wenn ich mir einen bauen würde,
dann wäre es wahrscheinlich
ein Ferrari-Rennwagen.
Ich liebe Ferraris.
Irgendwann mache ich das vielleicht, das
wäre lustig.
Schon jetzt seine Beerdigung als
einen gelungenen Abgang vorzubereiten,
diese verrückte Idee
hat Martin Brunnschweiler
seiner Frau zunächst verschwiegen.
Doch dann machte er eine
Ausstellung über seine Brauerei,
und der Sarg durfte nicht fehlen.
Meine Frau findet das nicht gut. Sie hält es für
makaber.
Sie denkt nicht gern über solche Dinge nach.
Mich freut es, wenn ich weiß:
Wenn ich gehe, dann gibt es für
all meine Freunde und die Menschen,
die ich kenne, genug Bier.
Dafür werde ich sorgen.
Es ist doch schön,
es dann allen so leicht zu machen,
wie es eben geht.
Er ist bestens vorbereitet.
Doch der Brite will noch lange leben
und seinen Biersarg höchstens
zum Probeliegen nutzen.